what about attractive women are they the
ones that are having a lot of sex or
attractive women extra promiscuous with
this dearth of globalized sexual
Marketplace and shakes on Instagram
being able to message them to come out
to Dubai well certainly the research
seems to indicate the opposite with the
most attractive women actually
indicating fewer partners and women who
are neither the least attractive nor the
most attractive reporting more sexual
partners and that's something that is
kind of in line with evolutionary
theories for why that might be right
because if you're a very very attractive
woman first I guess some background here
would be that women there's a huge
difference one of the most
well-replicated differences between men
and women given from evolutionary
psychology as far as you know
replication replication crisis and
psychology something that's very very
well replicated is very large
differences in socio-sexuality between
men and women men are very very open to
having a lot of sex many partners being
promiscuous women much much much less so
so given that basis
a very attractive woman physically has
many many more options she can be more
selective a woman who is slightly less
attractive say medium attractiveness or
something she may actually need to use
sex more to secure mates to secure a
partner or something like that and in
that sense sex serves as sort of a
function to secure a mate in that sense
and then people who are very very low at
the end of attractiveness they may have
difficulty finding a mate at all in that
case so that's probably how you get that
middle range of female attractiveness
that's associated with
uh more sexual partners men on the other
hand the most attractive men
attractiveness is linear as far as
predicting sexual partners for men but
it's also not a very very strong
correlation either what does incentivize
female short-term mating then
so certainly uh the Paradigm for
short-term mating
uh would be the Dual mate hypothesis in
evolutionary psychology for a long time
this is what it has been until
relatively recently right and the idea
here was that men and women but we'll
talk about women specifically in this
case uh have a dual strategy for
selecting a mate one strategy is looking
for a long-term mate
who can provide resources form a pair
bond and raise a child basically and the
other is a short-term strategy and that
short-term strategy was very closely
related to the ovulatory shift
hypothesis right because the idea is
that
uh when a woman is fertile she looks for
a man with good genes you know and gets
pregnant by this man so that she can
have the good genes and then at the same
time have this long-term mate at the
same time so this was an idea that
persisted for maybe a decade and a half
in evolutionary psychology and at this
point now evolutionary psychology has
shifted very very much away from that
they said you know there actually isn't
that much evidence for this dual mate
hypothesis something uh David bust and
Schmidt recently wrote in an article on
sexual strategies Theory which is what
I've just described it's called sexual
strategies Theory
was that really this short-term mating
strategy probably only applies to a very
very select few women and those are
going to be women who score very very
high in sociosexuality if you look at as
I mentioned sociosexuality big sex
differences if you were to look at the
two distributions they're about uh one
and a half standard deviations away from
one another if I remember correctly so a
lot of men and women don't even overlap
at all as far as these sociosexuality
scores
so what would drive short-term mating in
that case well one of the big motives
mentioned in the recent article by bus
and Schmidt would be money and certainly
that's not what a lot of people I think
think about when they have this
short-term mating discourse they think
oh they they want a Chad who's hot and
everything and all of that but if money
is a big one you know and you can see
this in things like sex work you can see
this in things like the kind of uh
who is this recently Leonardo DiCaprio
he finds very very young women now he
was an attractive man before but he's
getting very very old do we believe that
these women are interested in Leonardo
DiCaprio because he is an attractive man
or because he has many many resources so
these are things that would incentivize
short-term mate strategies but more
interesting than that perhaps is that
the shift has gone from saying ah people
have this all women have this dualistic
mating strategy short-term and long term
saying okay there's actually a lot of
overlap between short and long-term mate
strategies that short-term strategies
may actually be kind of a springboard or
a doorway in to long-term made
strategies
a good example of this reported by David
Buss in his research was that about 70
something percent of women who have
affairs they report for example being in
love with their Affair partner and this
has led to kind of this new paradigm in
evolutionary psychology that's called
the mate switching hypothesis which is
that short-term mating is not something
apart from long-term mating it's not
going out there to secure the good genes
it's looking for a new long-term mate so
this short-term mate this playing the
field outside might be like okay maybe
my satisfaction with this mate has
decreased but I don't want to break up
yet I need some kind of security going
into a new relationship so I'm kind of
exploring these short-term things to see
if they become something larger or
something longer in that sense yeah
women monkey branching from one
relationship to another I I found it so
interesting the because the the Dual
mating hypothesis was founded by bus as
well right
yeah so David David both comes up with
this Theory then he kind of reassesses
the data recants his original
um Theory and the problem is it's kind
of like the the same thing when you have
a newspaper article that accuses someone
of someone something and then publishes
a retraction a little bit further down
the line the issue that you've got is
the retraction never gets as much uh
exposure as the original accusation does
and now we are stuck in this sort of
liminal space where the guys that did
the study say that the study no longer
holds water and this original theory is
still continuing to kind of plow ahead
uh I I don't know
I I I can't really work out why it's the
case that the Dual mating hypothesis
seems to keep moving when the guys that
says it hasn't replicated either right
when they tried to do this again
certainly so something yeah that David
bus said in this recent paper it's
titled sexual strategies Theory 2021. it
might be a book chapter in the New
Oxford Handbook of evolutionary
psychology or it might just be a review
but you know he he says okay so these
aren't entirely contradictory you can
have short and long-term strategies but
this makes switching seems to be much
more common in this you know actual
women pursuing short-term strategies
pretty rare so that's something to
consider what hasn't replicated well so
one of the things uh that this was very
very heavily based on initially was it
was called you know the Dual mate
hypothesis but a longer title for this
or a version of this would be the Dual
mate hypothesis of ovulatory shifts and
the idea is that when women ovulate when
women are fertile that's when they're
especially attractive to men with good
genes right and that's when they're more
likely to cheat and all of that so
that's what specifically hasn't
replicated very well what we see instead
is actually that women are pretty much
attracted to the exact same type of men
for long term and for short-term
relationships the reassessment that bus
and Schmidt kind of made in this paper
was like okay so good genes are not just
physical either good genes include
things like intelligence they include
things like pro-social Behavior they
include the behaviors that would make
someone stay with a partner and raise a
child and provide resources and all of
that so why would none of those things
be selected for in a short term mate why
would it just be physical that's one
issue with that we don't see the shift
in actual preferences that's the big
thing that has not replicated that I
think undermined this a lot and kind of
caused that shift away from it was we
don't see that women seek men who are
more physically attractive when they're
ovulating they want physically
attractive men all the time and so
that's something you know if you talk
about the black pill they don't they're
not wrong about that people like
physically attractive people they like
facially attracted people muscular men
and that sort of thing that's a real
thing so and that's something that
persists for both long-term and
short-term so we don't see that there
another one uh that kind of hasn't
replicated well that would have lended
support to that as well was the good
genes uh immunocompetence testosterone
hypothesis and the idea is okay so when
women are ovulating they're attracted to
men who have very high testosterone high
testosterone signals good genes why is
that because high testosterone causes a
handicap in immunocompetence to have
high testosterone you're actually
lowering your immune system a little bit
and that means that you have to be
especially fit to have high testosterone
so none of that has really replicated
very well so many of these things that
we think of as signaling good genes from
an evolutionary standpoint perhaps they
don't we don't see the switch in mate
preferences for short-term and long term
as previously believed and we see in
actual Behavior as well as reports that
a lot of these short-term relationships
are kind of as you said they look more
like monkey branching than they do a
different strategy they look like
someone that wants to leave a
particularly I should say someone I say
a woman that wants to leave a
relationship and enter a new long-term
relationship there's huge differences in
sociosexuality huge sex differences and
preferences for monogamous relationships
as well all of that kind of leads toward
okay women probably are not engaging in
a lot of short-term mating and in a way
it's almost like when people talk about
women that way it's almost like they
ascribe more male personality
characteristics to women it's almost
like if I were a woman that's what I
would do but that's just you know women
are very different in a lot of these
ways what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]